Hello, everyone.
Hello, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for being late.
I literally was about to start and then I got the email
about the
VTuber Marvel Rivals thing.
I was just like, oh, okay, let me look through this.
And I was just like, I got really worried because like I
want this tournament to like go well, you know?
I don't know.
I was just, because there's only two tank players in this
tournament.
And, like, there's a lot of people that are like, I can
off-roll.
Because it's like, first choices.
Like, what's your main role?
And then they're like, okay, but what's your off-roll then?
So, you know, obviously, some of these players can off-roll.
But, you know, I can say I can off-roll as DPS.
But my off-roll as DPS is, like, plat.
Or some shit.
So it's not like, you know, I hit E-turn.
as support but then if I try to off-roll and I barely play
off-roll too so there's like some people that do play tank
as an off-roll but like I only have one person that does
that on my team so I got some I'm like well I see some teams
they do have off-rolls for tank there's one team that has
zero tank players I'm worried about them I don't know maybe
they'll surprise me maybe they don't need a tank player
they'll just they'll just like actually no they have okay
actually they have one it's like DPS and tank I think
they'll just like maybe they'll they have like and they have
an insane DPS player who needs a tank if you have an insane
DPS player to be fair um and but There is one team that has
like three, four off-rollers who can play tank.
So, like, uh, so there's that.
So it's like, I'm like, it's, it's really sad that we don't
have any B-Tuber tank players, which is understandable
because who the fuck wants to play tank?
I won't reveal, like, I, it's like, there's some people here
that will be very surprised that are participating here.
So I won't reveal who the people are, um, um, that are
participating.
Um.
and like I'll let you guys when it's revealed you guys would
know the thing is I'm like scared because I do want this to
be go well and like balancing is the hardest part but
there's no fucking vtuber tank players I'm so not surprised
because who wants to play tank it is actually like you gotta
be a masochist to want to play fucking tank anyway so I was
assigned captain but my concern like I'll be like you know
I'll be like super um straightforward with you guys I'll be
very transparent guys I don't want to be a captain I think I
have to be because like in my head if you're assigned
captain um um and if you're assigned captain it means like
you know you have like because it's it's a pre-assigned team
and um it's a pre-assigned team so I'm like why do we why do
I have to be captain I know it's like it's just a title but
I don't want the responsibility especially if it's a free
assigned team I'm I don't like responsibility if I if I have
no say in in what happened so yeah so I did email asking can
I like give up my
I just don't feel comfortable being a captain.
I just don't feel comfortable being a captain if there's no
captain duties.
You know what I'm saying?
I just wanted like, if there's no actual captain, like I'm
not drafting for players.
I'm not making the team or anything.
So I just feel like it's just a name.
So I'm like, it's possible if I just, I don't want, because
like, if anything happens to my team, people be like, Jokey
Brain.
And I just don't want that.
I don't want that.
If we get last place, they'll be like, Oh, Jokey Brain.
I'm like, no.
I don't, I don't want, don't, don't leave your name out of
your mouth.
Leave my name out of your mouth.
I was, I've got nothing to do with this.
Patrick has to think it was super chat thank you thank you
so humble we need a captain to keep it so that's like sorry
that's why I was late because I was like asking like um can
I give up my captain's spot I don't know maybe there's just
be like no and I'll be like okay I don't know you know it
doesn't hurt to ask it You know, it doesn't hurt to ask if
it's okay, but I don't know.
I feel like I feel like I'm still going to be captain, but
I'm just worried.
You know, I always get like super paranoid about these
tournaments.
It's like a double-edged sword because like there's so many
support players I feel like.
And I also was like saying like what I'm worried about is
that they think I haven't even played the new season yet i
haven't even played gambit i think if i was gambit maybe i
can carry but the thing is it it's considered a four fun
tournament but the literally first place is 7.5k thousand
dollars like 7.5k dollars that's like even though it's four
fun you know it's still a lot of money so it's not per
person obviously it's divided by six but like you know
everyone wins every team um every i mean you have to you
have to have prize money like you can't it's hard to make a
for fun tournament but also like make it fun for people to
watch as well you know because it's sponsored by marvel
rivals it is sponsored by you can't really blame them on
that because like you know it puts more stake into it and it
is sponsored by marvel rivals so of course you're gonna like
you know put in sponsor money into the like put a prize pool
and them and it's like you know it helps motivate to people
to so it's hard you can't really um it's hard to make it for
fun like you know my apex tournament had prize money too and
obviously people took it very seriously as well um you know
i was trying to push the for fun angle on it but you know
that's why i try to balance it with like you know fun game
modes where you don't really require aim but it's hard to
get people to participate if you don't have prize money and
everything so it makes sense like you know you want to put
more cred to your tournament so it makes sense to have um to
have a prize pool it like these tournaments always makes me
so fucking scared and paranoid because like i don't know how
it's gonna go because like i'm like first when i first
looked at it i was like this seems pretty hard to balance
because i'm like i don't know if this is unbalanced or not
like i can see some teams that felt like maybe you swap a
play like one or two Maybe it'll be better, but like, it's
so hard to balance because 80%, I think like 70% of the
players, okay, it's 1% tank players, if I'm being honest,
it's 1% tank players, 70% support players, and the rest are
DPS, and that is already very hard to balance if you have
that percentage of, yeah, the 1%...
You guys are gonna know how good it is because like a lot of
people are gonna be off rolling right now like for this
tournament Um Um, Ultron is fucking bad right now guys.
Ultron's bad Like it's all about Gambit.
It's all about whoever it's all If my team can play dive we
would fucking roll everyone.
That's all I'm gonna say Like If my team The thing is I
don't know if my team can play dive I don't know like
um it's either dive or mag um but i haven't even tried out
the new season you know i don't know so um um that's why i'm
like i'm so nervous like i i hate being so i was like so
excited to be of the, you know, the VTuber cup, but I'm
also, like, really, really nervous, because you know, I
don't, that's why I don't want to be captain.
Because there's so much uncertainty.
So I feel weird being captain, because I'm like, I don't
know.
This is, this is, I don't know.
I think there's is like just from my experience looking at
like knowing the gameplay of some of these players on here
and like knowing like their skill level i feel like there is
one team i know which team's gonna be first place it's not
my team but other than that like that's the only team i know
that's gonna be first place because they have a one above
all dps player um and that's the thing so hard to balance
because like the only other one above all player is me but
also i haven't i'm support
it's so it's like it's so scary because it's like what can i
do they play if they they play sidelock what can i do like i
can't solo a one above all sidelock player like I'm just,
I'm just a little guy.
I mean, maybe with Gambit, but like I said, I haven't even
played the new season yet.
Yeah, I'm just going to heal real hard.
No, you can't, no, no.
I will say it's easier to solo carry on DPS as in Marble
Rivals than it is in Overwatch.
In Overwatch, a lot of characters are more like, it's very
hard to solo carry.
Like back then in Overwatch, you can solo carry a game
easily.
Like you can just play Widowmaker and hit like, like kill
four people and then you win.
But now it's not.
Now it's a lot harder because all the tanks have 5,000 HP.
So it's a lot harder now.
Yeah, back then you can do like, you know, you can do
Nanoblade and then bam, easy.
Or like Bayblade with Reaper and a Nano boost.
not like that even even if you have a mercy pocket it's not
that easy anymore in overwatch in rivals however it is very
easy to solo carry as a dps all the way to celestial maybe
even eternity honestly to eternity it's so easy if you have
one pocket support on um and just gives you a snowflake or
even a mantis damage boost or anything you can solo carry as
a dps all the way to eternity um it's just that like it's
like um as someone that has played this is is like honestly
like very easy to do now um especially because the reason
why um that's not solo yet but it's still it's okay duo
maybe but you can still do it if you don't even have a
pocket you still do it without the pocket you just need to
know a good players will know where all the health packs are
located and because they know where all the health packs are
located um they don't have to have a pocket support as long
as they can know where the health packs are they can easily
like as like flankers or uh maybe even hella honestly like i
had games where i was like you know you guys have seen it
before where i would play hella and then i'd be in like
fucking plat or gold elo and i don't play hella a lot and
this is a long time ago and i was like playing hella and i
literally like just killed pop pop pop headshot headshot
everyone's dead we go in like doesn't matter just take care
of the people that don't position very well and then just go
pop pop headshot do headshots they're dead and that's like
yeah so like you can just click heads and and yeah it's just
point and click that's the thing that's what I'm most
nervous like worried about most nervous but I'm trying to be
like it's okay just come down Doki it's it's for fun I just
don't want to be captain
I don't want the responsibility of being captain.
But the thing is, I'm also a support player.
I don't really want to off-roll.
I'm not here to off-roll, too.
I just want to play support.
That's really it.
So, I don't know.
I don't know.
I think the teams are honestly going to say the same.
I think at best, if I could, just like, I just don't want
the name of CAF.
I just don't want the title.
Like, you know, if we get last place, at least they won't be
like Dokeybird.
Like, Team Dokeybird in fourth place.
Because I'd rather just like, I would be on a team that's
last place, but please don't call my name out.
Like, just don't call my name out.
Like, bro, come on.
It's just a title.
Come on.
I didn't even know I was going to be captain.
You know what?
I just found out I was going to be captain.
Like, like, an hour ago!
I just, yeah, I just, I just don't like it.
It's just more like PTSD and trauma for me.
I just, I don't know.
It's just like, it's just like PTSD, I guess.
Like, I just don't like it.
It just gives me like, oh.
As our team has fun, it shouldn't matter, right?
The thing is, you can, I know, like, people are like,
sometimes guys have fun but marva rivals is a hero shooter
and like if one team is like a lot weaker than the other i
don't know if this is balanced i can't tell so like i'm like
i believe i believe in the balancing team because this is
very hard to balance me looking at the me looking at the
roles and um looking at the roles of what they have to you
know work with it is definitely very hard to balance so i
can understand like if they've been like trying to struggle
trying to fucking find like um the best way to do this um
and uh but yeah no like if there is a huge difference in
skill level between teams obviously you can't really have
fun if you're getting spawn camps someone said so like
that's why like you know i'm glad i don't i'm not like you
know having to uh do this because like i even like i'm like
being like i don't know this is balanced i send my email but
like um um if anything is it possible i'm just not the
captain like
um uh and it's just like even i don't know because it's it's
like i'm i'm like how do you balance
getting no if you no okay you know what's the most tilting
thing getting killed by the same person five times in a row
i don't want my team to feel that i i don't want my team to
feel that you know like being killed by the same type person
five plus times in a row that's not fun
so like and i feel bad you know the thing i feel bad about
is that um the thing that i feel the most bad about is that
obviously they're like oh joki you've been top 500 before
but that was like you know i even wrote like it was the
early season like season zero to one i've been top 500
before and it's because of that peak that i like pull up my
team's average because of it so they have to find weaker you
know lower ranked teammates to balance it out so i i feel
really bad because all i can do is play support I don't even
care like they're like people and when I play ranked it'd be
like you play anything else and I'd be like no like no you
swap like you know I'm stubborn I don't fucking want to play
anything else like so like I haven't even touched the other
roles in a very long time so I'm like I don't care I'm just
gonna I'm still gonna play support I'll be like and then
they'll be like, oh, can you play tank?
I have zero hours in tank.
I can just say that.
And then they're like, okay, well, okay.
I yeah.
Yeah, I have fun with support.
I do.
I enjoy.
I enjoy playing support in Rivals.
So, yeah, I'm just nervous.
I'm really nervous about this event.
Ah, ah.
I'm nervous.
I really am.
Um, uh, okay, wait, give me a sec, let me, oh, I don't mind
if it's anyone in my team.
All right, here we go.
All right, um, no, I don't want to flex.
Because the thing is, when you're flexing, it has to be on
tank, and I don't fuck with that.
It's never DPS.
You can never flex on DPS, because there's like, like, 200
plus dps players like on my team it's never when you're
flexing it's never dps it's tank i don't want that i will
never be a tank player you can never get that out of me also
am i lagging a little bit with my fluid i can't tell i never
yeah it's never a dps flex you know it also for those who
don't know we didn't get nominated for uh marvel rival
streamer um i did cry a little i did a bit when because like
I I stayed I like uh my managers like do work I was like no
I'm watching them announce the nomination and then I got I
was like ha ha I was so confident you know I was like oh my
gosh silly dokey never go in with high expectations never go
in with high expectations dokey and then um I was so I was
like hopeful and confident because I was like truly I'd get
nominated right I was like I don't know I don't know why I
thought I'd get a nominated uh that I was like getting ready
to screenshot it on my phone as well because I was like I
can't get work done uh to my manager because I was like I'm
too busy like I have to know like it was like one hour
before the stream and it had to wait like 40 minutes while
in the start like I forgot that flesh tubers um when not
even flesh to but I think like twitch streamers for twitch
streamers I'm so used to just like going live after my intro
like I loop like two to three loops and then I swap.
and, you know, like, even then I was like, oh, your guys are
waiting too long in the waiting, like, waiting screen.
But I forgot that, like, not just Fleshdures, but, like,
Twitch streamers, their waiting stream can be, like, an hour
long before the actual stream.
Like, I forgot people do that on Twitch.
Not just, like I said, I've seen YouTubers do it, too.
They would, like, you know, they want people to gather in
first.
But I would, like, you know, the stream started I waited I
think like 40 plus minutes like 40 plus minutes before they
started the stream um like because it was like starting
stream you know the intro stream like the waiting like the
starting stream title thing and then I waited 40 minutes and
then they uh and then they started announcing the nomination
so I was obviously so antsy and everything um and so like
you know I got I was like I got my phone ready to screenshot
it And then I was like after the fifth name called I knew I
wasn't gonna be in it After I heard the fifth name I was
like I no I didn't make it So then I obviously I started
crying because I don't know I just thought that you know
Like you know people were like oh why are you so why are you
so like um to this like oh it's just a meaningless award the
thing is i put a lot of effort campaigning for it so like
you know and then it's like i thought it'd be really cool
and it'd be really nice to be like you know a vtuber
represent representative because you don't see vtubers
nominated outside of it's you barely see vtubers nominated
outside of like the vtuber category so um so that's why like
That's why I put so much, like, you know, expectations on
myself for it.
And I thought this was like, oh, yeah, this is like one of
the categories that VTubers have a chance to, like, shine
in.
Because, like, I did so much on Marvel Rivals as a VTuber.
And, like, Marvel sponsors me a lot.
And, like, sponsors me a lot for, like, their stuff.
And, you know, they usually just pick me on the VTuber side.
And it's all FleshTubers.
So, you know, I thought I, you know, I was like, oh, maybe
there's a possibility.
There's a chance.
and so that's why like you know i thought it'd be really
cool i was like oh that'd be such good like representation
you know be like look see a vtuber can like get on this
category as well like outside of the vtuber category because
it doesn't happen very often like um i know like iron mouse
she has got nominated various things outside of either
category and it puts a lot of exposure to vtubers in general
because you know it's a normie lots of normies watch this
like the people that are nominated also like it's the meta
for streaming changed so much it's mostly rl streaming it's
crazy um but like like you know it's also like you know a
lot of normies and like you know um watch the streamer
awards and like like especially like the streamers that can
nominate in these awards so it's like really good publicity
in general um so that's why you know i felt really bad i
felt really sad because i was like oh i can't believe i can
i was like oh my god i should oh like you know i was like oh
why did i thought i could do it like because I know a lot of
it's not your guys fault.
I just think that you know youtubers are still um a niche.
It's like a huge niche and honestly I feel like it's more so
like oh it's not because like okay that's what pissed me off
the most.
What the thing was pissing me off the most was that people
on my tweets you know of course you know all my tweets being
like my community didn't show up or like your community just
didn't vote for you and I was like that's a fucking lie.
I know so many And I know a lot of like VTubers from
different A lot of VTubers outside of my circle were saying
No vote for Doki Bird for Marvel Rivals So I was like
there's It's not my community not showing up It's not like
even the VTuber like The VTuber community even voted for me
In Marvel Rivals Like it wasn't just my community too So
it's just because this is my theory It's just that Because I
am not part of like i'm not like a normie streamer and we're
like vtubers you know like it's a it's still niche we're
still very niche we're part of a niche group within a niche
group because we're part of the anime group but anime is
already pretty niche and then within the and the thing is
like a lot of these uh normie streamers like normie viewers
viewers they'll be like i don't know anyone in marvel rivals
but hey this guy i've seen this guy play this game once and
he collabs with um the streamer
so I'm gonna vote for him I think it's just that like
they're just like you know they're voting for their favorite
norm like they're voting for their favorite blush tuber in
the categories and they got to the Marvel rival categories
and they'll be like I remember this oh yeah this guy this
guy played with um this guy played with my favorite streamer
one time and it was Marvel Rivals or like and I don't
remember he's she's Marvel Rivals I'm gonna vote for him too
like I don't know what he actually does but I'm gonna vote
for him because you know he he's like my favorite streamer's
friend or like he he uh he's collabed with my favorite
streamer and uh he uh he does I remember him seeing him
stream Marvel Ravos so it's just that and and it's just like
you know but obviously I don't know a lot of flesh tubers uh
so obviously like and like flesh like a lot of flesh tuber
viewers a lot of normies they don't really watch vtubers so
it's just basically that i just think i just don't have the
reach and i don't stream on twitch that often too i know a
lot of people are like oh you should do multi-streaming now
you know like hollow dive is doing multi-streaming now um
but like i feel so okay i don't know i know like i'm like
i'm like um stagnating my growth by not streaming on twitch
um I know that I know I'm stagnating my growth by being so
stubborn and splitting you know like doing Twitch as an
afterthought and for like extra bonus streams but like I
hate the chat restrictions I hate it so much and like I saw
like apparently also the fucking rules are so um unclear
because I saw like I saw someone I don't remember who it was
it was a while ago that was like trying to warn the hollow
live girls being like don't keep your don't keep two twitch
chat don't keep YouTube and twitch chat on the stream or
like you could get banned but apparently the rules are so
unclear and so poorly written you can apparently have both
twitch chat streams on like both chats on your screen but
they have to be divided like I don't know like they gotta be
segregated like They cannot touch.
It's crazy.
So you can have both chats.
They just can't touch.
They have to be on opposite sides of the screen.
Yeah, it's fucking weird.
I...
Like, yeah.
So, you have to have...
And they can't be, like, you know, like a little space
between them.
It has to be actually, like, on the other side.
Like...
it's so so because everyone thought that you can't have
youtube chat on if you're doing multi-streaming on twitch
but apparently the rules are so because that was like
everyone would parrot that like everyone was parrots it and
was like yeah um you can't have like you can't have them
like the screen you only can only have twitch chat because
like twitch will ban you if you have youtube chat on the
screen because that's how vague the rules are that's how
vague it is and um uh and then i found like we found out
later that no no you can't you can't have both chats they
just can't be together they just have to be like very
clearly separated um so that uh you can't have them there
also someone was like oh what about there's some streamers
that have them merged those streamers have a contract with
twitch that allows them to do that um because they don't
want them to leave their platform so they they have a
contract where they can merge their chats um but they're
very contract uh so um so there are some creators on twitch
that can merge it but if you aren't like you know you're not
one of those creators that have that contract obviously you
can't do it um it's you know it's makes sense because like
you don't want the streamer with 30 000 viewers leave your
platform like like you want it to go to your competitor like
no it's not just chat it's more so of like you know in the
contractors a lot of like stipulations and a lot of like
rules that you can bypass because you're like oh i want if
you want me on your platform um you want me to stream on
your platform like i'll do this and i would like this and
this and this um because like i say i that's the one reason
why i don't want to multi-stream because it's like it's ugly
i don't want to have both chats on opposite sides of the
screen it's so i would be like okay i mean if i could tiny
like you know the youtube chat is here and then the twitch
chat is like right under there like that's fine i'm fine
with that but the fact that i do two different chats on like
different it's just it's screen color i hate screen color i
just hate it like it just doesn't look good
no it has to you have to be like like very clearly separated
and every thing.
Um, I just, oh, that's what I hate.
That's what I hate.
I just like, they have to be like here and then the other
one will have to be like very clearly not touching each
other.
And I just, oh, it pisses me off.
Uh, there are a lot of years that do what you just said.
It's not allowed though.
It's not, I was reading that thread.
I won't say it, but like, no snitching, no snitching And
people were saying, it's just, it's just more so like, as
long as Twitch doesn't do anything to you, um, if one is
going up and one is going, they can't touch as one is going
up and one is going down, those are so fucking unclear.
I was reading the Twitter thread and I was looking at, like,
hololive, and they didn't want to, like, get in trouble.
So they separated it in two different sides.
um it's not so i was reading a thread and people were saying
it's not supposed they can't touch people were saying that
too and like that's what i'm saying it's so unclear it's so
fucking unclear because like the um the like and i know like
you know i don't want to fuck with twitch
they're so unclear i feel like the rules need to be more
clarified because i was reading the um and like people were
saying that like yeah like they're not supposed to touch and
i'm like okay
but like even before then even before then it was like
common knowledge where like twitch was like you can't you
can't have youtube chat on stream on screen like i was like
uh that's what they I just don't like having two chats on my
screen because of the clutter.
It's just, it already covers so much, you know?
I play video games.
I do a lot of gaming streams.
And like, the thing is, I try to minimize as much clutter as
possible.
And I don't like that, like, I don't like the fact that, you
know, like the chat can, having two chats can cover a lot,
up a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
One chat is fun.
It covers a lot of stuff that's on the screen when I already
have myself on screen as well.
Like, no, it's just because, like, you know, that's what
also is really hard about being a VTuber streamer.
It's because if you're doing like, if you're a Flesh
Trooper, you can just shrink your, you can just shrink your
cam and stuff.
But like, you know, a lot of people like watching VTuber
streamers for the VTuber on the screen.
And then that's already covering up like one fourth of the
game.
and and then it's like oh yeah it's just uh just shrink
yourself like what's the point i might as well not be on
screen it's like those like i shrink myself and i'm like
those like interpreter like the hand sign interpreter people
are like right on the bottom this will Just streak myself.
I'd be like, like the interpreter.
I'm doing my hand signs.
And doing like, oh, this is what she's saying.
Yeah, ASL Doki right here.
But yeah, I know I should multi-stream.
I know.
I just, I don't know.
I should suck up my integrity and pride.
I just wish the rules aren't so unclear.
Because it's like...
Now I'm finding out that apparently you can have...
Both chats touch each other.
But like, people were like arguing against that.
I was reading it up.
I was like, oh...
Because he can't look like it's merged.
So...
So it's like...
What if...
Like, are these rules that are actually like...
If Twitch doesn't like you, they'll give you like a
suspension?
Like, stuff like that.
Like, I...
You know, okay, someone...
Okay, someone earlier was saying that
Someone earlier When I streamed on Twitch They were saying
That like Oh Jokey, you changed the description on your
Twitch Because in my old description I was like, I stream on
YouTube more, follow me there And then when I found out Hala
I was doing multi-streams on Twitch Or like not multi-stream
was joining Twitch guidelines um this is the same day i saw
someone tweeting out like trying to warn the hollow girls
being like don't merge your chats or anything or don't have
both chats on screen because that's against the rules which
apparently isn't anymore like what the fuck like why are the
rules so unclear like so then i reread the rules again um i
reread the rules and um and then i found out You're not
supposed to advertise a different platform to encourage
viewers to come to that platform And I realized I've been
breaking the rules for a very long time So I quickly changed
it That
was the day I changed the description Because in there it
was like You're not supposed to encourage other your viewers
to come follow you on it
I quickly changed it because I was like oh fuck okay I No,
and you didn't get punished for it.
I think I sort of did because one of the twitch staff
unfriended me on discord and unfollowed me on Twitter Pretty
straight they're just like I don't want to deal with you.
I
So yeah Well, that was a long time ago.
No, it was before it was before like yeah it was it was a
while ago i just didn't realize it until like a couple like
a month or two ago i realized it because like my manager
asked me something about like oh you have a twitch staff i
could message about something and i was like yeah let me
look up and i was like wait i can't find them um my discord
friends list so so um no no they're still working there i
think i saw their twitter so i was just like oh let me no
problem let me find them on my discord friends list and i
was like wait they're not my friends list anymore and i was
like wait are you still following me on twitter i was like
oh they're not following me on twitter anymore so i was like
um that's awkward um i was like well i found their discord
handle but um they removed me on anything so um good good
luck um next seat thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you for what it's worth i do appreciate you just
stream on youtube it's comfy but i won't blame you decide to
dual stream i don't know i don't know i just i don't like um
i personally just i'm not a fan of dual streaming but it i'm
stagnating my growth by not full streaming because like i
said you know twitch is for any like english-speaking
streamers um youtube is more for um for like um you know for
live streams it's more of gear towards asia um twitch is for
eu and na and youtube is for bots like it's for video
Uploads, short form content.
It's not really for live.
Oh my god.
Okay.
So I was talking to Moxie and he was like, oh, he was like
checking, he's like sharing screen with me.
And he's like, I was like, yeah, no, I, she's like, oh, you
don't, I don't see it on Twitch often.
I was like, no, I do my streams on YouTube.
And then he like went on YouTube, well onto my channel and
was like, you don't have a lot of uploads.
I was like, no, you fucker.
It's on Click Live.
And he's
That's a tab?
I was like, oh my God, you fucking...
Because, you know, you go straight to videos.
Because, like, that's what people normally do.
And it's like, wait, what?
There is a tab called for live?
And I'm like, live?
I'm like, yes, you fuck?
Like, what the fuck?
That's my main platform.
Yeah, a lot of people don't know about YouTube live.
Mine is fucking blown.
yeah like
so so that it's a lot of people that don't know that a lot
especially a lot of normies that don't know that there is a
live tab on on youtube um so so that's why i know i'm i know
i'm not like i'm stunting my growth but i I hate it I hate
it I hate the new meta is multi streaming Because people are
like People you know are like You are You are not fucking
over your career You are more so like You are not taking
advantage Of the things Like the materials in front of you
By By not multi streaming And it's like Ah I hate splitting
viewerships too.
I hate it.
I hate it so much.
Um, I just want, you know, I just don't want to split
viewerships too.
I just want everyone to be here with me in one area.
No, I am a meta slave, though.
That's the worst part.
I'm a meta slave.
Uh, let's see.
There is a fundamental brand where there's people at brand
loyalty.
is about the only noticeable difference magic thank you
super chat thank you thank you thank you thank you uh crunch
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you uh
you're my favorite marvel i streamer you inspired me as i've
been in emotional slump and my room is cluttered i took your
advice and started it day by day thank you thank you thank
you i'm happy that you know you're taking the steps to uh
feel better about yourself it really does mean a lot uh to
help you with that um but yeah no like i said uh to go back
with the whole marvel i was saying i I mentioned I hated
that like like you know the randoms were like you know
blaming you guys it was fucking pissed me off like I didn't
care I like after the you know not knowing knowing that I
didn't get nominated I literally played fortnight through
two hours later like I I was okay you know I was sad you
know as I should be because like um I did spend a lot of
time campaigning um I spent a lot of time campaigning and I
also did bonus streams late at night um you know when i was
already so busy i was already so busy and i did do bonus
rival streams late at night so it wasn't like i didn't try i
think i felt like i did try and um so obviously you know
that's why people are like why are you so sad about this
meaningless award why are you like because i put so much
time and effort even though you guys might some of you guys
might think it's i still put effort into trying to campaign
so it you know in my in my head i feel like oh i've wasted
so much time i could have if i knew like you know it wasn't
possible i wouldn't have you took that time you know like so
that's why i didn't think you i personally didn't think it's
meaningless i thought like you know um it was it would have
been nice to you know be able to have a vtuber outside of
the vtuber category um in one of those spots um and then
okay another thing that i felt like i was getting rage
baited um was that um like we were like oh someone was like
you didn't even tweet about it that's a fucking lie someone
that was following me i i held my tongue was like i looked
at her twitter and she didn't even tweet tweet about asking
for a vote.
If anything, my tweet had the most likes out of all the
nominees that asked for a vote.
So don't fuck with me.
Because VTuber fans love Twitter.
They love interacting with Twitter.
Normies, for some reason, don't.
I was like, Normies don't interact with Twitter, but VTuber
fans fucking love interacting with Twitter.
Don't fuck with me.
Yeah, like, and then someone else that, that, um, yeah,
because we're chronically online, because that's how we
fucking were able to interact with our favorite anime
person.
Maybe they'll go out the street and be like, oh my god,
there's there's Kai Senat walking in Target You can catch
them, but you know how only we can see our favorite anime
girl or boy online So we have to be chronically online Like
You can look outside and then you'd be like, oh my god,
there's speed doing his running shit I don't fucking know
Like and then um and then another thing another thing that
um um that like fucked with rage baited me but i but i had
to say it because i was like i know i'm like oh i'm fine i'm
like after that but i had to talk about it was that uh i
remember reading not even just one person multiple people
were like oh it's just because you didn't stream enough of
arrivals all the other nominees um um trained more than you
and i was just like okay
and then i was like don't oh don't pull that card if
anything half the nominees streamed it when they were
sponsored don't Fuck with me.
Like, and, like, I don't say half.
Maybe, like, like, one or two.
And then, like, I know, like, one, another one, they, like,
basically, they, like, um, they, they stream it.
They do stream it, but they don't, like, stream it.
They are variety.
One or two of them are just variety.
And Rivals is their variety stream.
You know who else does that?
I'm considered a variety streamer, but I do stream rivals a
lot as well I even play rivals off stream so I was like you
cannot so like I'm just like oh my god like when I saw like
several people's commenting that I was like no you do no
that no me being a variety streamer doesn't fucking put me
out of the running because I still consistently stream
rivals outside of being sponsored.
But they're like implying that like the nominees weren't
also variety streamers?
Like I was like, if anything I think Bougar's the only pure
rival streamer in the nominations.
So I was just like, I was just like, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm pretty sure like three of them have the same consistency
as me in terms of like variety and streaming rivals.
So that's why I was just like, um that's why i was like you
can't use that argument for me
i even play off stream like i'm just like bro i that's how
i'm like bro i'm so i'm in so deep i play off stream like
have you ever seen tim play off stream bro he has a family
to take care of he's not fucked up like me like
he has a life outside like he ain't fucked up like me I play
off I play rivals at three in the morning off stream I ain't
here to make content out of it I actually just purely enjoy
the game like I purely enjoy the game so much that I will
not sleep to play rivals at three in the morning I have a
problem please understand like
He's very healthy.
Yo, I had so many people.
I bumped into...
While I was playing off stream, not at a degenerate hour.
Actually, at like, you know, 12 p.m.
or some shit.
Like, 12 or 1 p.m.
I bumped into...
What's his name?
The org that left.
By the way, 100 Thieves left the Marvel Rivals.
Didn't leave the Marvel Rivals.
For those who do follow Esports, 100 Thieves didn't leave
the Marvel Rivals scene.
They're just they just didn't want to pay I think they just
didn't want to play paid a roster before the new league was
announced because if they still have Here's a little like
esport like knowledge for you guys like business knowledge
like Net ease slash rivals haven't announced the new league
yet but there's no tournaments until 2026
because that's you know they're all losing money you know
like majority of esports orgs aren't making money um and you
know you know they don't want to pay their teams it's you
know they have to pay them monthly you know so it's easier
to not to kick you know to drop their team and wait until
the 2026 league is announced and then recruit a new team
because that's at least four months of not paying wages like
so so that's why that's why they drop their team because why
the fuck would they pay their the roster money when there's
no tournaments to enter like
it's messed up but esport orgs are not making money like
except for like that one percent i think the only i'm pretty
sure um the the the only esport org that i'm very confident
in that is making actual profit is t1 purely off of faker
that's it purely off of faker that's the only for org that
full confidence is making actual income and
nothing else i feel like i feel like i feel like t was the
only org um um so yeah so anyway back to my story uh back to
my story uh i was like 12 to 1 p.m and
Let's see.
Oh, yeah, I'm not captain.
Thank fucking God.
Yeah, I don't get to be captain.
Sorry, no, I just got the message.
They're like, you don't have to be captain.
Look, thank God.
I don't.
Yay.
They're like, oh, it'd be more publicity if you're like team
Doki brand.
I don't care Me already being in that team everyone knows
who I am I don't need to be like you don't have to like push
my name out there Like anyone that's watching for a mob
arrivals already knows my name.
It's fine Like I'm that much of a degenerate for this game
like on the VTuber side.
I think everyone's aware Yay dodging your responsibility
Yeah, I just don't want them to be like, oh, Team Doki
Braid, Lost, I just don't want people to say that, like,
I'm just, I'm just here for the ride, I don't want to be on
the driver, I don't want to be the driver's seat, um,
anyway, um, my, my story, my story, basically, um, Uh, uh,
so I bumped into, who is it?
Delena.
Sorry, I was like, do I remember the name?
I was like, one of the PS players.
It was like, is I heard Delena or Terra?
But I remember it was Delena.
Um, because he's the, uh, because I remember it was Delena.
Anyway, I bumped into Delena in rank.
Also, me, thank you for the 20 gift of ships.
Thank you.
I was like, oh, oh, and then Delena, I pulled up his stream.
He's part of 100 Thieves.
For those who don't follow Esports, he is part of 100
Thieves, and they are known as the best team in NA, but they
got fourth.
Was it third?
Or it was, was it third or fourth?
I don't remember.
They are the best team in NA, but, you know, EU fucked NA
hard.
So, doesn't matter because EU fucked NA.
It wasn't even like a challenge to that's the worst part
like you was so ahead of NA Like it was not even it was so
sad.
It wasn't even a goddamn challenge like It was just 3-0 done
like Sorry All right, oh fly quest was the okay, but under
these one first in the NA tournament.
But in the world, Land, they were fourth place.
Flyer Quest got third because Meta favored them.
Because the thing is, for those who don't follow Marvel
Rivals meta, I'm sorry, I'm info dumping you guys so hard.
People are like, I don't care about Marvel Rivals, but this
entire stream was one hour of me talking about Marvel
Rivals.
But basically, the thing is, after the NA tournament, meta,
like, they had to play on the new season patch.
So because of they had to play on the new season patch, the
from the NA tournament fully shifted in the world tournament
so and they only had I think like one month to prep for the
new meta so like you know that's not a lot of time so they
had one month to learn the entirely new meta I think was
less than that was it like only three weeks it was like two
to three weeks maybe yeah it was like two to three three
weeks between not even one month it was like two to three
weeks to learn an entire new meta with a new with some new
hero pools maybe like not you know your tanks or dps or
supports not their strongest hero pools um going into the
one million dollar land um because how's that different than
the others because it may dive a lot stronger the new meta
may dive so fucking strong because for those who don't know
the new meta was that they buffed venom for those who forgot
they heavily buffed majority of the dive characters and they
released daredevil so na has been practicing non-dive for
the entire time but in eu they've always been playing dive
so it for them there was like you know it's nothing changed
for them in general so in na they all don't know how to
learn dive in time in two to three weeks going in to a one
million dollar land and the best venom players in the world
are all eu players that's the thing europe all the best
captain america the best venom player the best angelo player
were all europeans We're the European pros.
So I would say the best non-dive kit, the best, you know,
the stationary tanks, you know, the best mag, the best
strange, the best Emma, those were NA.
But that doesn't matter.
Yeah, the best Captain Europe, basically.
No, Captain Europe.
It was literally Captain Europe.
So all the best stationary tanks were NA, and all the best
dive tanks.
were European, but the one million dollar land was literally
dive.
Like it was dive meta.
So like they can't end the thing is they're like, oh, why
don't you just replace the players in time for the rosters
were locked since the beginning.
So it's not like you can poach someone for the million
dollar land because the roster is locked before the first
tournament.
It was before the first tournament even started.
The regional tournaments, like NA tournament, European
tournament, Asia tournament, The rosters are fully locked
you can't change the roster until the end of the season
which is after the million dollar world tournament So you
know and it was pretty much fucked like It was so sad.
I watched the land.
I was so bored.
I'm sorry like cuz it was literally Even like the two best
European teams like it was a 3-1 during like first versus
second that was like the best dive players were all on the
first place team so i was it was literally like three one
and um and like i was just like okay it was so it was
one-sided as hell like it was not like it was like it was so
fucking one-sided there was no actual fight like you know
who's gonna win like it would be a miracle if the second
place team even put up much of a fight like the saddest part
was there was no fight there was no actual like you'll be
like fight back no they're dead like like half of them are
in a coma right now and half are like dead like
so so anyway back to my original story i'll now explain
sorry you guys needed to You guys didn't need the context of
you fucking NA hard, but like, I just wanted to tell you
guys, like, what it was like and what it might be like, too.
Um, anyway, back to my original story of, like, how much of
a degenerate I am.
Um, um, um, I bumped into Delana, who's his 100 Thieves, and
I pulled up his snow because they were streaming.
with like another pro player but they were both solo because
you know like like i'd say it's such a weird twitch meta now
where like even though you're not streaming streaming
together like you're actually you're not like playing
together a lot of the smaller streamers they do the stream
together just so they can combine all their viewerships
together to be on the top of the twitch page in twitch
category is very smart but it fucks with commute interaction
i think it's like you get no community and you don't get a
community because you're not interacting with chat because
everybody's chat is combined so how the fuck are you gonna
read your own chat then like you know your chat has to read
everyone else's chats too so you're not building your
community but um it's not cynical because like how can you
you know how can you build your community if you don't have
your community um so um so so like The thing is, they all
combine it, too.
So I don't know why they do.
They all combine.
I think they combine it to make their chat look active.
Um, you know, because they'll be like, oh, why does it say
this much viewership?
They do it to, like, make it so their chat, um, chat looks
very active.
So, um, anyway, sorry, that's not even part of the original
story.
Anyway, bumped into Delena.
Back to the original story.
And, um, he, like, randomly, he was like, he was, I was
watching the VOD because I was like, oh, hey, Delena was on
my team.
we lost obviously um because like we had someone throwing on
our team i don't remember what was going on but you know um
i am an e-o-m um terrorist so like it like it just follows
me so at that point i'm not even like surprised that we had
someone throwing anyway um and you realize then elena try to
add me uh to invite me to play um because i've never talked
to him before um the one interaction i had was when i also
got him in a game on stream and then he started throwing.
I was like, because, but before he started throwing, sorry,
this is another tangent.
You guys might remember the story, like remember the stream,
but I got Delana in my game like a long time ago.
And, um, I was like, look guys, it's Delana from 100
Thieves.
And Delana was like, is that the real dokey bird?
And I said nothing.
And then he swapped the squirrel girl and started throwing.
And I was like, guys, I should have told him I am the real
dokey bird.
Like, I was like, guys, I fucked up.
I should have told him.
showed him so he wouldn't throw like and then I think and
then he realized I was the real bokeh bird and then he like
he like swapped back to um he swat back to like a real DPS
character uh and then that was my and then he went into my
chat and was like we should play together so now I was like
yeah sure add me and that was like four months ago so that
was like the last interaction that was the only the first
and only interaction i've had with delena anyway fast
forward to like last week bumped into him again and then
obviously i wasn't streaming because i i play for the love
of the game not because i want to just make like you know
just not because i want to have to stream it or anything i
actually enjoy playing this game off stream um um i looked
at his chat because after the game I looked at his chat and
then I was I was afk and I came back and then I saw his chat
because I wanted to see like oh do you say anything did he
notice I was in his game and um and um in the chat they're
like oh dokeybird uh dokeybird uh what is it called what's
that lingo people use nowadays when oh don't know wall view
I was like what does that twitch lingo um they're like wow i
can't believe dokeyberg dono wild you or like yeah she
doesn't acknowledge you bro and i was like what i was so
confused i was like what the fuck i didn't do anything like
they didn't even ask you they didn't say anything to me and
apparently um dono wild means like um they like try to talk
to you but you ignore them so like uh so they don't talk
like you don't talk to them until you don't i think it's
like they don't talk to you they're like trying to imply
that you they don't acknowledge you unless you give money to
them i think that's That means, and you know that I don't
don't know all you guys, because I'm literally interacting
with all you guys, and I don't have a super chat right now,
like, yeah, yeah, guys, no one super chatted me, and I still
talk to you guys, right, I still read a comment in the chat,
so I don't know walling, also thank you for the Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, we had a great stream.
And so, also, Nexi, thank you.
Let's see what we chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, so, um, what happened was that, and I re-watched the
VOD, and he was like, wait, is that Doki Bird the real one?
And then he was, like, asking his friend, he was like, yo,
was she streaming right now?
And then he was like, nah, she offline.
He was like, what the?
And they were like, what the fuck?
They were like, what the fuck?
Why is she like, bro, she played for the love of the game,
bro?
They were like, they couldn't comprehend the fact that I was
playing off stream.
I was like, like, funky freak.
Like, bro, you think she plays her fun, bro?
Like,
so whatever you're thinking of Super Chat, Thank you.
Thank you.
Let me fix that for you.
Lord Corrosus, thank you.
Thank you.
That's ridiculous.
You miss super chats all the time and we love you anyway.
Yeah.
I'm the reverse dono, Walter.
I'm Waldo.
I don't know.
Patroesso, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I play because I have a problem.
Quick throw.
Mule is super chats to smoke screen here.
Mr. Broken ball.
Thank you.
The super chat.
All I have is $5.
Link, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God.
I'm donut walling right now.
Is this what donut walling feels like?
Just reading my super chats.
Don't stop donut walling us.
Thank you, the super chat.
Link, thank you, thank you.
Billy, thank you, whatever.
The 10 gift that shows.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's me.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sometimes donut seems to hurt your chances of being noticed.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Patroesu, they even super chatty, thank you.
Anyway, I think that's really all there is about...
Um...
Sorry, I had to reread the message right now.
But that's really all about my rivals.
We're over.
The rivals tangent is done.
What if I just play rivals right now?
But I won't do that to you guys right yet.
the bank story okay okay oh my god i fucking hate my bank i
wish i could call them out but i can't yeah because it's a
very canadian specific bank oh god i fucking i know like
some people if you're a canadian i feel like some of you
guys already sort of know which bank it is because there's
only one really fucking terrible canadian bank
and i'm definitely okay i'll tell you i'll give you guys
this context um my picked this bank um because she knew it
was a bad bank and like so so like she was like she wanted
to take advantage of that and like disgusting and anyway so
um I didn't realize how bad of a bank um this particular
bank was until all the problems um all the problems showed
up while I was trying
so um you know after i started living on my own and taking
back my own business um i really i because i didn't because
like my mom handled controlled the banks she controlled the
business and um so i didn't realize how bad this bank was
until i took re-took over my entire business Plus ago.
So, and like started living on my own.
And then I, oh my God, cannot wait for me to leave this
bank.
I, oh, I'm, oh my God.
Okay, so anyway, I fucking have to go through so much shit.
No, she just took control over the business and my bank,
like the bank, the business bank account.
Because she was the one that opened, she was the one that
opened the business bank account.
it and um and she picked this bank so god i hate this bank
by the way like i know i keep saying it but bro it's so
fucking bad i'm gonna tell you why this new story you guys
already know so many stories about this bank um uh ashram
thank you for the five gift of ships thank you thing the
thing is when i took over the um when i took over this my
business again and also the bank accounts I created a new
business bank account under a new business name, you know,
because I wanted to like, you know, I wanted to go clean
slate.
Like, you know, this is my own business.
My parents are not involved in this.
This is my own.
And I went with the same bank because I didn't realize how
fucking bad it was.
Because I was like, well, my parents, my mom picked this
bank.
So clearly she knew what she was doing.
So I might as well go with the same bank.
So because, like, obviously there shouldn't be any problems.
was so fucking wrong.
There were so many problems.
Because I didn't realize how bad it was until I had to take
over it.
But it was so late.
I already made a new bank account with my new business
underneath this particular bank.
But yes, some guys, some of the Canadians who know about the
worst bank in Canada know exactly which bank it because
there's only one really bad bank in Canada one exceptionally
terrible bank in Canada and so um um anyway so today um I
had to call them because I'm tired of doing wire transfers
by going to the branch because every other fucking bank in
the world does not require you to go to travel to the branch
to do wire transfers um and so I was like obviously uh maybe
uh maybe you know I'm gonna call them because like I was
talking to my manager about this because like they're like
okay you have to pay this person you have to pay that person
and i was like and they're like did you pay this person yet
i was like no because i have to walk over to the bank um to
i have to do like a like a really long walk to the bank to
do it and i don't want to do it for one wire transfer so i'm
waiting for it to all build up until and then i go there and
i just do like four to five wire transfers um at once so you
know because i don't fucking, you know, just do it one at a
time.
So they're like, what the fuck?
So my bad just like, what the fuck?
Like, you know, like, he knows it.
He knows I have to do it.
He's like, he still can't, he still can't wrap his head
around.
Because I've told this to him multiple times.
But he still can't wrap it around in his head that I have to
walk over there to do the wire transfer.
And I was like, what, isn't that how all, like when I first
told him this, he's like, I was like, isn't that how all
banks do that?
And he's like, no.
He's like, no, what the, yeah, in the 70s.
Like, yeah.
He's like, I don't know.
In the fucking 70s, like, it's 2025.
Like, so, you're like, yeah, maybe 30 years ago, maybe.
Like, not now.
Like, everyone thinks it's did it.
I was like, what?
I was like, no, that's not true.
They don't defeat.
I asked so many.
They're like, you gotta go to the branch to do your wire
transfers.
And no, I'm not talking about e-transfers.
I meant wire transfer, international wire transfers that
cannot do online, apparently.
And then, like, when I pay, like, Americans like they are
like just do it online here's their information and I was
like I had to walk to sorry I had like you're like oh can
you not send the payment like today I was like no I have to
walk to the branch and it's like 9 p.m.
now and it's closed they're like obviously like my American
my American like people that pay they're like what the fuck
do you mean like just do it I'm like no, I can't do that.
The bank is closed.
I can't I can't just like I'm sorry the bank is closed Or
I'll be like I'm sorry.
It's Sunday, so I'm sorry sir.
It's Sunday.
I can't I have to wait until after Sunday To go to the bank
to do this wire transfer.
I can't do it.
It's closed like
So Um, so anyway Uh, I was like, I like called them today
because I was like, I can't keep doing this.
I can't keep walking it to the bank.
Um, I can't keep walking to the bank to like make a, uh,
wire transfer.
Like, it's just not convenient or like, it's just, it's so
un, it's so unorthodox.
of him to do so no Canada is so fucking weird with
technology they're like they're like I swear to God there's
so much bureaucracy in Canada and like there's so much
bureaucracy in Canada and like so many hoops to jump through
I feel like i'm not living in the 21st century like like
it's just canada it's literally just canadian things
so um anyway um so i called i called my mink and now it's
just like i called my branch and i was want to like uh want
to know like i have to um i have okay i lied by the way i
had so i called my bank and i started lying and i was like
oh i have to go out of country um in like um in like a month
or two and um i have to go to the states and the thing is um
um this bank bank branch it's gonna be very far away to
where i have to where you know where i have to be stationed
for my business trip um and i'll be staying there for like a
couple of months so i was just wondering if there is a way
because if i say like oh i wonder why it transfers why i
live close by in canada they'll be like oh i'm sorry ma'am
just go to the nearest t
I'm sorry, a lot of rage came in.
Sorry, just go to the nearest bank branch.
Sorry, I said just go to the, I'm sorry to say the newest
bank branch.
And then you'll be fine because, you know, it's Canada.
It's Canada.
And I said the bank, the Canadian bank.
Anyway, yeah, I was trying to say the bank.
Anyway, anyway, yeah, so as I was saying, So, obviously, I
had to make up a scenario to, like, figure out what the fuck
to do.
for the wide transfer and so sorry my Canadian accent went
really strong there um so I was saying like oh like in one
to two months I have a business trip where I have to be in
the States for a while so I was wondering um like the
closest uh bank um like the closest branch of your bank
Um, so I have a lot of important wire transfers I have to
make for my business.
So I was wondering, like, uh, I was what, well, I used to
work for this crowd.
Yeah, it was bad.
I, it was so bad.
It's, it still is.
Um, anyway, I was wondering if there is like an easier way
to do this wire transfer because I don't want to travel an
hour or two away.
to an hour or two away to do this wire transfer.
You know, obviously.
But like, they'll do, like, no, I just don't want to walk,
like, I just didn't walk, like, several walks to this
goddamn fucking bank, like, in general.
Even though the walk is, like, less than 30 minutes, I don't
fucking want to walk there.
Like, he doesn't know I'm actually still going to be in
Canada.
I was like, anyway, so the guy, he was like, oh, we have
something called the global money transfer.
And you can do that online or on your app.
And I was like, oh, really?
And he was like, yeah, it's called the global money
transfer.
And your account should be able to do it.
And you can do it online.
And it's really simple.
Just check it out on your app or on your PC.
And I was like, can't be that easy.
Like, surely it can't be that easy.
So I was like, okay, sure.
All right, thank you.
And then, you know, stupid me.
Instead of, you know, trying it out right away, I walked
dead.
I ate dinner.
the the bank is closed i got on my pc um and looked for it
global money transfer for my bank i logged into my bank
account i clicked on the option global money transfer um and
then what do i see your account is not eligible for global
money transfer uh you are small business account um please
go to wire transfer to see how you can do wire transfer
by the way when i called my branch they are very aware that
my account is a small business account and they still
recommended me global money transfer
So, so I'm like thinking, why the fuck did you recommend me
this?
When you know damn well my account is not eligible.
So, I don't know, I don't know what to do, I don't fucking
know what to do, I don't know, maybe I'll call tomorrow, I
don't fucking know, by the way, by the way, here's a little
other My bank told me because I was like, oh, I'm going to
be in the States and like maybe in a month or two for a
business trip.
And they were like, oh, yeah, we can't really help you when
you're in the States, by the way, ma'am.
Because our bank in America, even though we have branches
there, it's not owned by us.
It's owned by the United States.
So like, it's actually a different company that operates
our...
The bank's there.
So, like, we can't really help you much for your Canadian
accounts if you're going to be using the American branch
side of our bank.
And I'm like, are you fucking kidding me?
What do you mean?
Then why are they called
by the Canadian side?
It's owned by the America.
And it's apparently a fully different corporation that runs
the American...
American side Like I was like you have the same name and
logo Like I was like what do you mean they get so If I go to
the American Branch of this particular bank they will not be
able to assist me on my Canadian accounts because they do
not have the oh my god what's the word they do not have the
access to it because they are the american branch side and
it's owned by a different corporation so
they don't have the authority to access or the
infrastructure to access my account and And I'm like, what?
And then, and then, they were like, also, um, ma'am, if, um,
if we have to send you anything, like, new cards or, uh,
they're like, if you need, we need to send you anything,
like, um, new cards or, uh, new credit cards or any banking
information.
via mail um we won't be able to send it to you at your uh
american address or any of the american branches because
like we said we have no affiliation with the american side
of our bank because it is owned by a different corporation
um i was like what and um you'll only be able to pick it up
when you're back in canada and i was just like what if i'm
stay there for what am I gonna do with my business I'm just
like because I'm just like actual skin walker big so I'm
just like what's what would I do if I had to like go on a
business trip for like I don't know, half a year, like, in
not even just the States, but just, like, somewhere else in
the world.
Like, what the fuck am I going to do?
Like, that's not a big...
I was like, it's so inconvenient.
And I swear to God, you know which bank I miss?
HSBC, I miss them.
I miss HSBC so much.
They treated me like a queen.
They...
Oh my god.
HSBC and Royal Bank treated me like a fucking queen.
I...
Oh my god.
Oh.
Because like HSBC got bought by...
royal bank so they they stopped existing in Canada I don't
know they're still around I know like majority um majority
of the HSBC bank for those who don't know HSBC it's a Hong
Kong uh bank um but majority of HSBC um um banks in Canada
got bought back bought off by royal bank and then like my
account got transferred to my HSBC account got transferred
to the royal bank again I still have my royal bank account
um but they they treated me like a queen
oh my god i i swear i might just transfer my i might just i
might just like whenever i have time i need to move all my
funds out and just go to royal bank because it's royal royal
bank treating me royally like I'm coming back I'm coming
back yeah anything will be better than the fuck the fuck I
have to deal with anything will be much better okay next see
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I would try
calling up and asking them to enable the global transfer for
your account otherwise you're gonna have to change banks
might work thank you the super chat thank you thank you yeah
i'm gonna call tomorrow when my branch is open about my
about the global transfer option because i was like what do
you mean like i was not eligible for global transfer like i
was encouraged to use it all right uh but no it's the royal
bank of canada i assume that's what rbc means let me check
all right yeah royal bank of canada um i'm willing to call
out royal bank of canada because they've always treated me
right they've they've never fucked with me they've always
been so nice to me like for those who are like wondering
like oh man like what the fuck is wrong with cat Let me tell
you a story about one time I had to deal, I had to deal with
Canadian, with Canadian airports.
This was a long time, this was a while ago, but it was when,
this was a long time ago, When we were trying to like, this
was not with dad.
This was for another, like our older dog.
And we had to like, we had to like fly us and our dog to
like, I think it was to the States.
No, no.
It was, oh my God, it wasn't even to the States.
It was like somewhere in Canada.
We had to fly to somewhere in Canada.
And we had to bring our other dog.
It was a weiner dog too.
And we brought, we wanted to bring, put him in like the
sitting seat and everything.
We wanted to bring him in with the, like, you know, put him
under the, like the sitting area.
And so like down there in the storage for the bags.
So, you know, we brought our little, our dog carrier.
But there's a lot of rules for the play.
And the thing is...
With these rules, they're like, we won't let you, the
carrier has to be this size.
The carrier has to be this size.
And also, um, but it has to be big enough for your dog.
But it has to be this size.
The thing is, so we bought this carrier that we thought that
was good size requirement for our dog.
we're like this should be good because there's enough space
for him and also it seems all right so we brought it along
and then everything seems fine until the magic came over and
was like your carrier's too big and we're like what and
they're like what kind of dog is it and they looked at it
and they're like oh he's gonna be you need a smaller carrier
but if you get a small carrier for him he's too long for it
so it's not comfortable so we cannot accept this carrier
because whatever side even if you get the correct carrier
the size carrier um he the dog is too long for it so i was
obviously my parents and i we were so confused because we
were like but this is This is a normal carrier that we
bought in Ikea like
Yeah, the dog was too long because he was a weiner dog.
So we bought like anything shorter because the carrier was
just too long So so we bought everything shorter He will not
be able to like Stand in it like he won't be able to like
stand stretched out in it because he's just too long so so
they're like um so then we had that no it was the the cabin
the cabin so so they're like you have to we you have to go
out and buy a it was like the metal the kennel we have to
put our dog like we were trying to avoid putting our dog in
the baggage storage because like you know we don't know how
he's like we we were scared i was gonna give him trauma
because like i assume it's gonna be really cold and really
loud so we wanted to go with the um because he's still a
small dog so we wanted to go with the care like the the
carrier option and they were like yeah we don't we sold out
of kennels so um you're gonna have to go out to nearest pet
store um and uh buy a
as he's comfortable.
So I was just like, but after all of that, um, we were,
they're like, okay, um, everything that I can check in now.
And, and then this was a night flight.
Okay.
For those who don't know, in the, um, in the, uh, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, the, the security sector, they close
at around, I think like they close at night.
So I don't remember it was like go i don't remember it was
like 11 30 or 10 30.
so the thing is i think it was 11 30.
so security closes at 11 30 so it doesn't matter if like you
know the flight is like 12 oh i think it's 10 30 i think
it's 10 30 because so they're like it doesn't matter if your
flight is like midnight or anything it doesn't matter like
the security closes at 10 30 so you have to get past it
before
So, I was like, I was like, oh, we're all so early.
Yay.
We're going to be able to make it in time.
And also grab dinner.
I'm so hungry.
So, so we were like, you know, an hour plus early.
And I was like, yippee, we're going to grab dinner.
And then we, you know, we had to do a lot, like whoever, if
anyone, to anyone that has ever, um, shipped their pet in a
kennel, um, on a plane trip, uh, never have hope, Doki.
Anyway, um, little Doki knows she was not about to get
there.
So, um, um, so anyway.
Um, no, it was like an hour before 1030.
It was more than an hour before 1030.
So, you know, we got, we checked everything in, our baggage
and everything.
And then, um, and then, you know, we had all the tags for
the dog for the kennel stuff.
Like, all there was so much stuff, you know, like tags and
like, um, wires and stuff like that.
You have to lock it, all the cages and everything, all these
stickers.
Wait right here.
You gotta wait for a person to help you bring your dog
through security.
We were like, me and my family were like, okay.
So we waited.
And we waited.
And then the lady, or sorry, the man that was like, you
know, the flight, I don't know what they're called.
The people that were helping you check in baggage people
were like making calls.
everything because the thing is the dog needs to go through
their own form of security before they are able to go
through um to the plane but we had to be there so we waited
and then 30 minutes past the flight attendant the the the is
it flight attendant like they were the ones that check in
your your tickets and your luggage they're like they made
another call i was like where are you you know like where
are you so then we're like oh and then finally um a guy
pushing cart came over and yeah they need to ask my dog some
questions they want to know where is he going like why are
you going there so the airline sorry sorry so then you know
a guy came over with a cart and he was like he's like all
right we're here we're here so we're like where do we go
yeah they're like okay you have to take your dog over there
like pointing vaguely so we were so confused my family and i
were so confused by the way like you know there is 30
minutes have passed by then so we were very confused we're
like okay um and then um okay we're gonna stop the story
here because i need to blow my nose give me a sec i don't
have tissue right oh wait i do never mind jk i just gotta
mute myself sorry cliffhanger does this dog have But that's
the thing.
That's what the security is for.
They want to check the kennel if there's fucking bombs or
drugs hidden in his fucking blankets.
So...
What the fuck the dog is doing?
The dog is the bomb.
So, anyway, um, that was the whole point.
Anyway, so, yeah, it's my dog a terrorist.
So, um, um, anyway so we were confused me my family and the
cart pusher were so confused because i don't fucking know
why he doesn't know where to go because we assumed that he
knew where to go just because like you know it's his job
like the the airline staff literally called him over to take
our dog to wherever he's supposed to go so we're just
standing here and then the security
the line for the security went up to us and was like um you
guys gotta hurry um because um security closes at uh 10 30
and you won't be able to enter like enter through the gates
after that so obviously we were like panicking because um
there was 30 minutes left before security closes so we're
like And then one of the one guy one of the security the the
security staff that checks like um oversized baggages or
like and like um to put bags through the check-in badge came
over and was like you pointing to the guy pushing the car
you um you need to go all under underground and then around
and it's through this door so you can go through the staff
door with the dog um oh no you have to go through here so we
can get you checked out um and you have to go through all
the way from the underground staff door yeah it's a maze
apparently and then and through that door through this door
to come to security um and then he didn't have to bring the
dog but the staff had to do that because it's part of like
security to make sure the staff doesn't carry anything like
to make sure the staff also isn't hiding anything dangerous
so and then the staff was like what do you mean that's not
how we do it and then the security guy was like no that's
how our airport has done this this always so i don't know
and then like the attendant the airline attendant came over
and was like no that's not how we do it i don't understand
that's not how we always do it and then the I was like, no,
we've always done this for years.
I don't know why.
You don't know the proper protocols of how to do it.
Because we're like, why can't we just push the cart over to
the security check?
Because it was just in front of us.
It was literally 10 steps away.
Like we literally, and he was like, you can bring the dog
over and put the cart here.
And we walked 10 steps.
Put the dog in the security check table.
and and um and then later he was like all right now you to
the staff guy you have to go underground go around here take
the elevator come back up and show up from this door and
then we can do the security check on the dog and then me and
my family just stood there and waited for this one guy to
show up from that one door.
And then the scaredy guy was like, it's protocol.
Like, you have to do it.
We've done, this is how we do all our pet checks.
I'm like, why does he have to go through some fucking hunger
game trials?
Like, he doesn't even, like, we don't even know this man.
He just worked for the airline.
Like, I don't know this guy.
So, okay.
For those, let me see if I can draw this out.
So, and then, like, it's just airport bureaucracy.
Okay.
All right.
And then...
Okay, I'm gonna draw this out.
It's gonna be really bad.
And then...
And then there's...
Man.
The security man.
Okay, so... Okay, so let me draw this out.
Okay, I don't know if it makes sense at all, but basically,
all right, let me grab the picture.
Okay, so there's a dog.
There's me and my family.
There's a security man, and the staff guy has to come out
from this door, and he will not accept anything else.
He cannot show up, you know, through the hot like through
the regular people area He has to show up from this door and
only this door like
So the thing is to get to this door.
Let me draw another dot like picture for you guys So is that
This Okay, okay, wait, wait This is the door He had there's
like An underground system He has to go through an elevator
He takes an elevator L and it goes Straight down and then
there's like The door
From what he was Explaining Okay And then second first
elevator there you go he has to go through first elevator
and then to the second elevator second and then this is the
dog sorry I'm not drawing anything yet alright there you go
I'm not showing anything yet okay here you go
it's I fucking hate Canada sometimes.
I hate the bureaucracy and how backwards everything is.
So, here's another picture.
So, to illustrate.
To illustrate this.
He has to go through.
He could, you know, he could just walk to the there and then
we're all here.
But the thing is, he has to take the first episode.
elevator and then go through this like a maze and then go to
the second elevator and then because let's go through
security sorry there's security right here okay sorry let me
draw like red like beep beep beep beep security security
there you go So...
So, yeah, it's like the Disney tunnels.
So, he's got to do his own security right here.
And he's like, you know, first elevator, second, and then
security down here.
And then that's not us, by the way.
It's the staff member.
Like...
And it takes the second elevator to go through this store.
This door right here while we're all waiting so it was like,
you know white rabbit tapping the clock tick-tock tick-tock
like when it
So we waited and we waited and then we're like where the
fuck is this guy Like the security guy was like don't worry
like he'll show up soon like he'll show up soon don't worry
we've done this many times he'll show up and my parents and
i we waited and 10 minutes passed fifth another five minutes
passed soon there was 10 minutes till 10 30.
it was 10 20 and the guy has yet to show up and then and
then one of the ladies at the other security booth came up
to us and was like he came back he didn't know where to go
and he came back and we were like what
what do you mean he came back up
There were five minutes left.
And the security guy was like, was like, okay, let me get
the flight attendant to stay on standby.
Because like, the thing is, While we were waiting, he was
like, I'll just do the security check now.
And then all we had to do is wait for him to show up and we
can drop the dog in the cart and he can take it to the
plane.
So we're like, okay.
So he was just literally, you know, like, I don't, it wasn't
even that complicated of the security check.
Like, all he had to do was just pat the bed to make sure we
didn't fucking sneak in each.
He wasn't even touching the dog.
He didn't care if the dog had a goddamn bomb or drugs up his
ass.
He was making sure that the bomb and the drugs was not in
the bed.
That's it.
And so he was just patting the bed and making sure.
And it was like, you know, we were like, hold your dog.
And we're like, okay.
And then he was just patting the bed and everything.
And it was done in like, like three minutes.
He didn't care if the dog had anything.
Just as long as it's not in the bed or in the kennel.
And then we put the dog back into the kennel.
And then we're just waiting for the security.
Waiting for the staff guy to push our dog.
Through like the security area to the play.
And...
and then when we realized it five minutes left um the
security guy was like okay we're gonna get the we're i'm
going to the flight attendant and like he's just gonna stand
there and wait for you guys because like protocol wise thank
god he finally fucking broke protocol because he was like
yeah no you just you sorry i think it was 11 30 by the way
it was definitely it was 11 30 it was not 10 30 because I
feel like 10 30 the restaurants will still be open but it
was like and then he's like you stand there and wait with
where the staff got to show up so so the family can go
through security and we managed to go through we were the
last people and literally it was three minutes left till
closing we're literally the last people that went through
security and we did not get dinner because everything was
closed.
So little dokey, so bright, hopeful, and did not eat
anything for dinner because all she was thinking about was,
yippee!
I can't wait to get some food inside.
Because I was like, Mama, can we get white spot?
Because, like, there's white spot right now.
Can we get white spot before we check in and then mama was
like don't worry we can eat inside the terminal i was like
okay because we passed by a white spot i was like mama
there's a white spot in the in the airport can i grab white
i'm so hungry can i grab a white spot
Sorry, little turkey.
Yeah, so...
Poor little turkey.
Like, yippee!
I can win the tournament, huh?
The only meal that sad child ever eaten in Forturus is
disappointment, red tape, and society on the side.
Patreus, do they even super chat that you can take it?
What was the weirdest part?
I was like, I'm so We got finally got through security And
everything.
I was like Mama There's a vending Machine.
I'm so thirsty Do you think we can Get to the vending
Machine and get some water And some snacks, Mama?
And then Mama And Papa was like Let's head to our gate first
Just head to our gate first before there's vending machines
there.
So we'll get there first, okay?
And then we'll get to grab you the water and the snacks.
I was like, okay.
And then we get to our gate.
And I looked around and I was like, Mama, where are the
vending machines?
Where's the vending machine, mama?
So,
girl, and then mama and papa were like, don't worry, there's
food in the airplane.
We can get food in the airplane.
And I was like, okay.
Now we're in the plane.
i was like mama i'm so hungry
do they have food i want to eat some i want to eat some food
i don't want i don't want snacks i want food you know i
didn't know a savory i don't have to say savory food because
like i'm a fucking cat and then and then they're like yeah
well the flight attendant and the flight attendant came over
here and I was like what do you have mr.
tenant do you have I don't know I'm like so southern as a
kid I don't know why I'm southern I'm like mr.
tenant do you have food on the plane and tenant was like oh
yes we have pretzels that's right oh I was like Oh Oh
Oh you have like Real food And then The flight attendant Was
like Oh yes we're gonna be serving Um breakfast in Um In
like four hours Tiny toky, tiny hungry toky was like, Mama.
Mama.
Wait.
I'm so hungry.
I guess I'll take the press And even I By the way guys I
don't like pretzels i never liked them i just i don't like
the taste of pretzels it's just so bland
so i had pretzels i had pretzels and then i waited four
hours support breakfast especially no you don't understand
airplane pretzels ain't it guys airport airplane pretzels
ain't it i could have got white spot i could have got white
spot instead no it's a hard airport pretzels too it ain't it
it's not good like what's the deal with airplane food uh the
swords and thank you the super chat thank you thank you um
paturetsu thank you with super chat thank you thank you the
only meal that side child will ever eat in airport terminals
this disappointment red tape and society on the side how you
have here thank you with super chat thank you thank you
thank you in puerto rico it's past your bag through
agricultural check then drop off your packs then go through
tsa thank you with super chat thank you thank you oh psycho
they use super chat they can thank you one hour about marvel
rivals 30 minutes about canadian bank and now little doky
trauma that's my sad oh she thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you this is my free therapy session this is
cheaper than therapy i just trauma dumped you guys and now
you guys know why i'm the way i am like now you're like why
is she always laughing and i'm just like i'm sorry you know
it's like the it's like i'm sorry i i all i can do is laugh
through this trauma like oh that's all i can do like um
patra said thank you for the super chat thank you Thank you.
You'll have to keep from crying.
Exactly.
We're talking rogo, we're talking real genuine soft baked
pretzels.
Were they unsalted?
Was there no sauce?
Was it literally a hard baked no salt.
The airplane way.
That's how much, that's how traumatic it was.
The fact that I remember what the fuck these pretzels taste
like.
You do not understand.
I was so hungry.
I, little Nookie only had lunch.
And then she had to take a fucking night flight past her
bedtime.
And now I was promised food.
I was like, mama, can I go to White Spot?
Like, couldn't get my little pirate ship.
My pirate ship, Nookies.
For those who don't know, White Spot.
is like white spot is like a family canadian restaurant and
like they have a kids meal where it's literally a pirate
ship and then they give you dino nuggets and i couldn't have
my dino nuggets i've been through so much no pirate ship
dino nuggets
um yeah thank you for super chat thank you thank you from a
young age don't key rod dog airplane travel that's my og
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you the worst
part that flight that flight i had to take the plane did not
have a screen no screens at all no tv screen in front of me
no tv screen coming out from the plane on the top i true
moment there you know and as a child that is not how you
want to go that's not how you want to go no name thank you a
super chat thank you thank you suffering builds character i
have so much character i that's why i have such a big
personality nothing yeah nothing but turbulence yeah so i
feel like this was like all trauma it's just it's just it's
just trauma all the ways i'm sorry my hangout session is my
free therapy session it really is pat and hugs for current
and past toky Yeah.
Oh, but anyway, that's how fucked Canadian bureaucracy is.
I mean, I told you guys the vet stories.
Like, that shit is wild.
The hoops I have to jump through to, like, get my dog
prescription and everything.
I think that shit.
By the way, I recently learned that Canadian...
I thought, guys, I thought Canadian Amazon, oh, oh my gosh,
okay, so I found out the difference between, like, Canadian
Amazon and American Amazon.
So, like, one of my friends, they were asking me about,
like, the dog food that I have to, like, the special diet,
and they're like, oh, what kind of, like, dog food, because
they were planning on putting their dog on a special diet as
well.
so they were like asking what brand it was and I was like oh
um it's hills um that's the brand I use and my dog is on
kidney care and then they're like oh yeah I'm gonna try and
order it because I was like you can just order it off of
Amazon because that's what I do and they're like oh okay so
they try to order it off of Amazon and then they're like
wait it says I need like a prescription from my vet I was
like what the fuck you know like what do you mean so
apparently special diets for dogs or America, um, your vet
has to prescribe it to you.
But in Canada, they don't fucking care.
Just order it off of Amazon.
Yeah.
So I'm like, you have to like grab a special number from
your vet to like be given permission to order like special
food for your pets in America.
But in Canada, I literally find the food and then I order it
off of Amazon.
I get it in one to two days.
Because our food, there's no, it's not a prescription.
You know, it's just like recommended.
They're like, yeah, we recommend you get this dog food.
And then like, I just order it.
Like it's, yeah, it's, you can't just, that's like, it's so
weird.
I was like, what?
Like, I should just buy it off of Amazon.
It comes in in one to two days.
Like, it's so...
But the thing is, it's so weird.
It's so weird.
Like, there's, like, certain things you can't just order off
of Amazon Canada.
Certain things you can, apparently, in America.
It's, like, so weird.
Hmm.
Because, in Canada, there are, like, you know, medication
and, and, like, not, like, you know, bad drugs, but, like,
medication drugs that you have to be prescribed on.
or you have to prescribe to get it.
And like, you can't get off the counter or anything.
Like, you actually have to ask the, you have to ask the
pharmacist to, like, grab, like, some certain medications or
some certain, like, special drugs, monitor drugs or
anything, like, from the pharmacist to be able to purchase
it because it's all, like, locked, like, behind counter.
But then, I found out, because, like, one time, similar
story um they're asking me about a certain medication i
forgot what it was i was like oh yeah yeah i can um yeah you
can just grab that um you can have you get it like uh uh you
have to ask the pharmacist uh to be able to or get it
prescribed and you're like oh i could just order it off of
amazon i was like what what do you mean by that yeah see
comes in like or two days i just it's just on amazon i was
like what the do you mean i have to walk to the pharmacy and
ask if they have it in stock and then like purchase it at
the pharmacy i was like what do you mean you can just order
it online yeah so it was like yeah apparently what was it
melatonin for melatonin in canada you can't just amazon
order melatonin you have to you have to get that like
because you know you have to ask the pharmacist like to be
like oh yeah I would like to have some um but like in
America you can just Amazon order it you don't need a
prescription you just have to go to the pharmacy and like
you have to go to the pharmacy and ask for it but Because
it's off the counter.
It's not on the counter.
You have to ask for it and be like, um, can I get some
melatonin?
And they're like, yeah, yeah.
Um.
Um, oh, is it now off the shelf?
I remember before it was like, you have to go to the
pharmacy.
You have to like, just be like, can I have like melatonin?
Uh, I guess, I guess we passed the law and be like, you can
do it now.
But there are some medications That like, I don't remember
which one it was I don't remember which medication it was
Cause like, it was a while ago And they're like, no, I'm
just ordering it off of Amazon I was like, what the fuck do
you mean?
I have to fucking I was like, I have to walk to the pharmacy
Like, what do you mean?
You can just order it online
Yeah, um, so like It's fucking, I hate Ken, the bureaucracy,
but like sometimes it's good.
Sometimes we have some positives, like, you know, we can, at
least we can order, at least we can order dog food online.
Like, this is the thing I don't understand.
We need a prescription, like in America, you need a
prescription for dog food, but like, who the fuck cares
about human medication?
Who the fuck cares about human medication?
like it's just uh no but the thing is you yes you can order
dog food online but like it has to be prescribed like the
special diet ones the special diet ones it has to you have
to get your vet to like prescribe you the special food but
in canada that you don't do that you just fucking order it
online like like the vet just recommends you the food and
then literally on amazon two to three days it's over like i
don't have to give them any information it just arrives but
in america it's like you have to jump through so many hoops
to give your dog special food but then like if you want to
order like medication or like any special type of drugs for
like you Like the actual, not the illegal ones, the legal
ones.
The pharmaceutical drugs.
Like, you could just order that off of Amazon.
Who the fuck cares?
Like, the fuck.
Yeah.
The fuck cares.
Um.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
TSB collab tomorrow.
Oh, it's not tomorrow.
I think it's, uh, it's the day after tomorrow.
Unless you're like, uh, so it's, it's on, it's on.
Thursday?
Yeah, it's on Thursday.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's the story behind the name?
For those who've never heard of TSB, the team, it's Team
Snake Bite.
So the name is Team Snake Bite.
And the team name came from... It was part of an Apex
tournament.
And it was based...
We had other names at first.
There was other names.
And then um we i asked a very important question because i
used to ask this question a lot to my homies because i want
to know if they're a true homie or not you know like this is
the only question this is a question that you ask people to
know if they're a bro or not if they're a real homie and
it's basically like if a snake bit your dick would you would
you suck the poison out of the dick like or let your homie
die so so obviously this is like the only question you ask
Like, it's the ultimate vibe check, you know?
Like, it's the ultimate bro check to see if, like, he's a
real homie or not.
So, I asked that question, and then I was like, we were
like, we were brainstorming names before, and I'm like, and
then we were, like, having a huge debate and everything,
because Axel wouldn't do it, and he still wouldn't.
It's been years, and he still wouldn't save a homie.
Let that guy die.
He's like, I ain't sucking poison out.
it is like, fuck that shit.
And I was like, bro, that didn't cool, man.
And then I was like, guys, let her call herself Team Snake
Bite.
So, so, so after we were arguing for like an hour straight
whether or not like he was like what like about why he
should do it and then we were talking about like coffee
pasta and then the chat started spamming like do not wallow
tsp is here to swallow if he's low then you gotta blow for a
win to keep you gotta go deep our throats will get till we
get the bag so like when we're in the tournament people will
start like spamming this to cheer for us on like broadcasts
and stuff because you know that's what people do back then
like you know like copy pasta like oh my gosh there was like
so like you know in esports if you guys ever watched esports
people would make like dumb ass copy pastas but they're so
fucking clever there's so many like clever shit i don't
remember does anyone remember like the classic esport copy
pastas that people used to do when you're cheering for your
teams i can't remember them on the top of my head but we
were like replicating that because like you know that brings
team like brings like people to cheer for like you know when
they want cheer for their team um people would start
chanting these things out so we're like oh we should we
should make one for our team you know so yeah like people
can spam that like to um spam this yeah spam this pine to
help c9 like shit like that like yeah spam this noodle to
help skedoodle like people would spam that in esports so
like in like esport tournaments like in any game like league
counter strike overwatch like shit like that so we're like
oh my god guys we should do something similar for our team
like so to bring up like team spirit for like people who
want to cheer for us so that's where tsb came from it was
like one of the most the one of and then the thing is by
calling us tsb um it was a japanese tournament because we
called ourselves tsb we didn't call us a team snake bite we
just put tsb so the japanese viewers and the japanese
commentators did not know the context behind our names they
don't know what the fly the fuck we called ourselves TSB
because like we gave zero context um because we didn't
explain it like because we were just called TSB so they're
like oh TSB TSB you know so there was like no actual context
so people were like oh it's so it's so say so it's so normal
but the English speaking side knows the real story they know
why we were called TSB in the true context so um the
Japanese side didn't know why they just thought it was oh
TSB you know just TSB like yeah little do they know yeah one
of the commenters praising how cool the name was because it
sounded cool you know TSB But then we're actually called
Team Snakebite because we're like, will you suck your would
you suck the poison out of your homies dick like It's like
sweet summer child you don't know the real context Do they
know they didn't know So that's the context of TSBU is
honestly one of the greatest group names of I've ever came
up with.
Dude, bear.
Chat came up with it, but I stole it and took credit.
Because I was like, I looked at chat and someone was like,
you should call yourself Team Snakebite.
I was like, oh my God, guys, we should call ourselves Team
Snakebite.
I don't even know which chatter said that, too.
The credit's mine, though.
Like, I saw it in chat.
the name and I was like guys I got a great name for us we
should call ourselves Team Snakefight like it did came from
my chat though so I was like yoink I demand the royalties
like you still owe us a blend no I don't know what you're
talking about Patrasu thank you for the hook a soup but
thank you thank you winners change history it's okay it's
because you guys are a hive mind and I'm the hive.
Anyway guys, anyway guys, I think this is a good time to
end.
I'm not here to avoid anything, but I think this is a good
time to call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me.
Oh my gosh, we yapped for so long.
That was fun yapping session today.
Fun hangout session, everyone.
But anyway guys, thank you all for hanging out with me
today.
I hope you guys you guys enjoyed my trauma dump today too
I always love talking to all you guys I always vibe a lot
with everyone it's always fun hanging out and you know I
always appreciate you dragoons anyways oh yeah before I go
before I go please check out my controller it really does
help a lot if you support and pre-order the void gaming
controller wait give me a sec I gotta find it though let me
find the png real quick i have so many dumb things
downloaded on my on my thing i don't know where it is give
me a sec guys let me find wait what did i not oh no did i
where did i save it when did i my god there's so many things
that i save wait sort by date modify i thought i have
I'm a little, I'm a little, I'm a little cuckoo today.
Well, where is it?
Wait, guys, don't go yet.
Don't go.
I have to show.
Guys, please don't go.
I thought, oh, there it is.
I found it.
All right, there you go.
The Doki Bird Controller.
Guys, please, we have a week and a half left to pre-order it
before it's gone.
So please, pre-order it.
order your very own dokeybird controller if we get enough
controllers we might be able to do other types of
controllers wink wink wink wink okay i'd say wink but i'm
not winking um wink wink wink wink wink all right here let
me yes please please pre-order um this controller It really
does help me out a lot.
It also helps out our collab partner here as well.
So yeah, please feel free to pre-order this.
It really does help out a lot.
And, you know, if this does well, we'll have more
opportunities in the future for more cool merch.
So please, we have a week and a half left.
So place your orders before it's gone.
Yeah!
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing are you still for me head to bed cause you deserve
it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye